you can't start a wall in a single day
you can see even even in a single second
so for me i started a war
a war not against a specific person not
against a human being but against a
seamless enemy and this enemy was
statistics
was reality
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opwest hillel stanford leap
and birthright xl an in media
partnership with ctek
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders i'm really honored to be hosting
a good friend today dr maor fareed a
lecturer and fulbright scholar at the
technon at mit and a member of harvard's
leadership program
he completed his phd with honors as the
youngest graduate of the technion at the
age of 24 focusing on seismic protection
of nuclear reactors he served as a
captain and ai researcher in unit 8200
and was acknowledged as an excellent
scientist top three academics in the idf
farweed is the founder and ceo of lil
modla
in hebrew learn to succeed an ngo for
empowering youth at risk from the
israeli periphery and the author of the
top seller learned to succeed malfoy how
are you doing fantastic how are you my
friend thank you so much for meeting me
here the last time we met was it i was
at boston right in the mit campus
absolutely technical harvard mit
endless scholarships uh author forbes
anything that i can say it's just going
to degrade what you've done already so
i'm not going to even try
but but one of the most incredible
things that that you're doing mo is that
your your ability to articulate to your
passions
and and inspire those around you those
that grew up with you or grew up in a
similar nature to the way you grew up
which i think is is a fascinating
journey to uncover and that's exactly
what i want to do in these 20 minutes
you're doing incredible ai research with
all these universities but but we're
going to put that aside for now because
i want to talk about my own and i want
to understand who is this who is the
person behind the doctor right you
absolutely take me back a little bit
yeah so i was born in a very difficult
neighborhood in a city called nestiona
to a beautiful couple of parents um
but unfortunately they were not
fortunate enough to have a
formal education as kids and as a result
their future was
dictated by those
consequences it means that they have to
work in
three jobs each
so it means that we couldn't really see
them as children and due to the fact
that i was living in a very difficult
neighborhood
and i had severe adhd that were
diagnosed much later on
i became a very upset and very violent
kid
and i was the problematic kid at school
and i was the the hated kid among the
teachers so
i didn't know exactly what i should do
at school and until one one evening my
father told me the words that i care
with me until this day he told me my all
learned that he won't become like me
and you know for a child
when his parent tells him that
you shouldn't become like me it breaks
something inside in his heart
and this was the first thing that i
remember like the the sense of something
that is breaking inside me
the second one was that i don't know
what studying is i don't know why it is
so important but i know this is the goal
of my life i have to do it not for
myself not in order to be a an mit uh
doctors or something like that
the main goal is better future for my
parents for my family i hope
for my younger brother and sister so
this was my goal
since this day on and later the the
story wrote himself i i guess now walk
me back a little bit so even even at
that moment you're not just taking it
too hard and saying okay i'm going to
make a switch first of all what is that
switch like so you go you go to sleep
that night yeah it's it's not like you
you can you know just change all your
friends in one day you can obviously you
can't move cities in one day you can't
move to a new location yeah but you
can't start a wall in a single day you
can see even even in a single second so
for me i started a war a war not against
a specific person not against a human
being but against a seamless enemy and
this enemy was statistics
was reality
for me i know i knew at this point that
studying is not easy and it's not
something that we do people like us i
didn't know what is people like us but
my father my mother my younger brother
and sister my family no one goes really
to school no one talks about studying
and i knew that this is this is the
world that i have to fight not for
myself but for them i imagine that i'm
leading an army of people that are not
really collaborating with with me but
but
put their hopes on my shoulders this was
what i felt and i felt that i'm fighting
the war
and so
how does that tangibly happen
how old are you at that point i was in
in sixth grade something like that sixth
grade yeah yeah at sixth grade you go to
school the next day is this an immediate
switch is this a gradual switch for you
uh so both uh the first moment that you
you realize that you're in a wall so
you're going to school in another
mindset
and then the change
increasingly
emerges so it becomes it becomes it
changes you very gradually and very
slowly but the state of mind changes
immediately so at the moment that the
mindset changes your grades are not
changing immediately it takes time but
you know that you're you're going to
fail a lot of time but you're not going
to give up
so this was
the quick change and the slow
change that went with time so walk me
through some of the milestones because
you're not you not only succeeded
yourself in accomplishing what you
wanted to accomplish but you also worked
tirelessly to create an organization
that is then helping others uncover or
or enter a similar war yeah you did
absolutely so for the first thing was
that i you know i was super excited by
um you know
the hope that i give to my parents but
it wasn't enough
even when i got the phd it wasn't enough
i i went from the stage at the technion
and i brought the diploma to my parents
and i felt like this catalysis that i
accomplished something that i fixed
something i closed the circle
in the in the universe but it wasn't
enough because it was only a single
circle
and i wanted to close circles of other
people i know that as we speak as we
speak you and me i know that a one child
um goes to to to rob at rob a bank and
then another girl when he goes to do
prostitution i all that people's lives
are breaking in front of in front of our
eyes and it doesn't even matter to
statistics to our enemy
and i knew that my my goal my bigger
goal in life is to help them in order to
close
their circles because i know that when
you have a dream
the the next thing that you're going to
have is hope
when you have hope you can't lose any
war
maybe you can lose several battles but
you won't lose the war so this is what i
wanted to bring to those kids so what
does it mean to learn to succeed well
how does that concept even work to be
able to learn to succeed yeah first of
first of all you have to have a dream
when you have a dream you don't have
time to go to you know to rob banks and
even to be the the violent kid in your
in your neighborhood in on or in your
class you have to to accomplish
something you have to be in a process
when you understand that you are inside
a process
all the other skills are emerging in
yourself so when you have a dream you
you pave your way towards this goal and
then you are committed to the process
and then you have to you know how to
organize your time your schedule etc etc
so everything is derived from this dream
from this whole right and so you take
that with you and how do you think about
the scale of this so how do you actually
go about and try to think how do you
take this this deep understanding which
this deep conviction that you grew up
with that you took in in the craziest
way how do you install that that
conviction and others yes so uh i think
that scale is the word that
it is so important in this process
because i know that i can do it by
myself i knew it all the time so this
why i wanted to to make this word
spread across people that are not those
children but where are those children so
my colleagues today that graduated from
the social and economical periphery that
are now
engineers pilots doctors etc
they have i told them that their goal
exactly like mine their goal is also to
fight statistics and they can do it by
themselves they have to join
this movement called learn to succeed in
moodle
and teach others and
and transform the world forward to other
children this is what we're doing is
it's almost like a responsibility
absolutely this is the world this is
very our responsibility and now as you
continue throughout your milestones
whether it be in 8200 or technion or mit
at harvard and the incredible research
you're doing
what part is this play in your life
right now yes so it it's
every time everything i do is
this goal is with me so i see
all the other things that i do as
platforms in order to make this
phenomena expand for example when i'm
doing research at the technion i just i
don't just do research in attacking and
i i host
the
the open days of the technion for
children four teens for youths and i uh
bring people from the periphery to the
campus of the technion and show them the
labs and everything
because einstein said something which is
uh for me it is very
very close to my heart you know in
shmoni my time we have a we have bad
hamashes
is the base in which we go through our
courses and right so i was a commander
there
and in the building that i was teaching
i saw like a quote of by albert einstein
that told
um
how he exactly said that he said
that
example is not the best way to educate
it is the only way to educate
so i think i think that
myself you know in all my endeavors for
academia and for and for business and
everything i keep this in mind and i
remember where i came from and to bring
those children those fields into those
corridors in order to be inspired and
so growing up with violence with adhd
in in poor socioeconomic conditions in
comparison to what one might expect what
is happening what is happening today
where is more today just give me a taste
of some of the really cool things that
you're doing yeah you know
intellectually you know the rigorous
because you're not just motivating
others you're also doing incredible
research for the world yeah so um so my
research at the technical and mit is a
joint work between mit and and the
technion so basically we're
studying a chaotic systems or stochastic
systems
and they predict
disasters in those systems for example a
flattering wing of airplanes and
earthquakes and and a break of uh
leakage in in
nuclear reactors uh using ai and the
concept of of the chaos theory so it's
basically combining my phd
research and my
experience from schwannoma time from
9200 this is what i do at mit and and
the techy and this is only one example
and in learn to succeed i am the founder
and ceo we're just expanding and
expanding every year so currently we are
helping 5 000 youth at risk every year
wow across the country to pursue their
dreams and find and pursue their dreams
and also the director of the israeli
center of scientists at mit and i'm also
in the program of emerging leaders of
the harvard kennedy school
so i'm dividing myself among all those
those stuff and i'm
grateful that i have this opportunity to
do all those things so what's the
passion where where does it all what
does it all come down to yeah you know
what what is sort of the goal the vision
the goal is is to shrink the gap between
the socio-economical periphery and all
the other
population in israel this is my goal and
it's not only for the next year or two
years this is for
the entire life that i was going i'm
going to wishfully have
so this is the thing and i will do
everything in my powers in order to do
that so currently is to uh through the
ngo
and through the academia
in the future it may be it will be
through business and and you know as i'm
going forward in my life and i remember
my friends from schmonema time 8200 and
i see their fascinating things that they
are doing and the technology that i
develop at the taking on mit i feel that
this is the next stage in order to
inspire
the social economic apparatus and in
order to give them not only hope but
bread on the table because i have to
share with you something when the corona
began
you know i i i
i committed in my life in order to
inspire and give them tools but when
corona when coveted 19 began
i felt that something is maybe missing
uh you know
i work with thousands of children across
the country but several kids are
very close to my heart and i talk to
them with on a daily daily basis
so i had one kid that i was calling uh
that i was talking with every week
almost
and when covert began in israel i know
that the the
the
economical situation was deteriorating
and i kept in touch with this kid i knew
that his stories of course is very hard
he's an orphan from his mother that they
passed
because of cancer
and his father is struggling in order to
to uh to earn the minimum wage in
israel
the minimal salary
so
i was contacted him every every day
almost and then he stopped answering the
phone i i realized from one phone call
to another that something is becoming
worse and worse
later i discovered that he
just committed suicide
what it means for me of course that i
take it personally of course i take it
as a personal
failure but i know i knew that he lost
hope the thing that i i
i put my life on the line in order to
give this one thing to him but now i
know that hope is not only matter of
force and not only in inspiration but it
also depends on the bread on the table
so as a shmani matam graduate as a
technion mit graduate i know
that my way to put bread on the table is
using technology
so now is to use technology as a
platform to give those kids bread on the
table and now we are working on
great projects that i
don't i can't really talk about right
now but i know that this is the next
thing that we have to do now to put the
bread on the table for many
wow wow
your journey is inspiring you are
inspiring i've been following for such a
long time we've been friends for a long
time and
and i i gained so much of my energy from
you so thank you thank you for
everything that you're doing thank you
and i love the the mission and i love
the vision of the technology as an
enabler academia as an enabler
to put bread on the table to inspire to
give hope but then to put it on the
table i have a few last questions about
you before we finish
take me back to your childhood again to
your childhood with the violence and
with the problems
there must be something very curious
about you if you're doing what you're
doing today you must have also been
curious back then what what really
fascinated you as a kid
i can talk about uh by being fascinated
by science and by computers because i
was i was in the
computer class in my in my high school
but all of those are just platforms i
have to be frank with you those are
platforms and the most the most
inspiring thing for me is giving hope to
my family and this is the strongest
thing possible i know that our
generation is fascinated by
entrepreneurship and innovation you know
everything is family but but the bread
on the table again
hopeful bread on the table this is the
strongest thing that that a kid can have
and the the pain and the sorrow in his
father's eyes i think nothing is so
strong like that
sixth grade unbelievable and you've
obviously answered you know what
inspires you today and i think that that
inspiration is is just incredible yeah
as a child it was hope for my family now
it's hope for the people exactly
and what are three words you would
choose for yourself or if i would ask
anybody that is that knows mo really
well what are three words that might try
to capture whom always the first one is
is i think hope is the word that is very
strong in my mind
i think the next one it defines myself
much it is simple simplicity
because people ask me about uh you know
how is to be it's my time and mit and
all those stuff
i don't see it as something that defines
myself
i remember where i came from
and i think the third the third word is
this is family is my root is where i
came from and i'm not talking about
yourself and masala my parents and my
brothers jesus i see the people of
israel i know it's something it sounds a
cliche but i see the people of israel as
my my family and also the people of the
world because we are part of a huge
network a living network and we love
everyone uh from all the peoples around
the world so i think this is also our
mission as the people of israel
for the rest of the peoples
[Music]
you